never does this how do i surprise him in
return
and okay he brings this knight out most
common at grandmaster level is to bring
the other knight out the kingside knight
on the right flank
and levan iranian reacts in maybe the
most combative way the most provocative
way just pushes the corner pawn not
fighting for the center yet lev on
ironian and now magnus has an issue to
to uh contend with does he
kind of take uh the provocation does he
grab the ball by the horns and say yes
i'm going to push all my pawns forward
i'm going to explode open the center or
in this situation where he's already 1.9
one point up does he just play solid and
slowly develop his pieces this is really
interesting match strategy from levon
ironian forcing magnus to make big
decisions and it's only moved through
yeah and magnus burning a bit of time
and incidentally
with this
second this move on the second go well
this is actually something that magnus
carlsen has played himself with the
black pieces against alireza farouja